les acteurs de la culture continue de
faire part de leur ras-le-bol face aux
mesures de restriction des
manifestations ont eu lieu hier à lyon
mais aussi à paris les intermittents du
spectacle occupent toujours le théâtre
de l'odéon dans la capitale ils
réclament la prolongation de leurs
droits mais aussi une rencontre avec le
premier ministre le point sur la
situation avec notre reporter nadège
abderrazak d'intermittents du spectacle
et des acteurs des secteurs de la
culture et de l'événementiel bloc
nuitées jours le théâtre de l'odéon
ils demandent la réouverture des lieux
culturels et le prolongement pour toute
l'année 2000 21 de l'année blanche alors
ce dispositif d'année blanche prolonge
la durée d'indemnisation de l'ensemble
des intermittents jusqu'au 31 août 2021
et malgré cela beaucoup dont l'acteur
robin renucci et disent qu'il est plus
qu urgent de rouvrir les lieux culturels
le lieu du théâtre c'est le dieu pour se
retrouver nécessaires dans les plus
brefs délais et avec soin les musées
bien sûr mais en même temps et surtout
un accord politique c'est à dire avec le
cadre des syndicats donc il s'agit à la
fois de réouvrir les lieux culturels et
en même temps de négocier les conditions
de cette réouverture de telle sorte que
les plus précaires ne soit pas davantage
soumis à cette pression qui est sur eux
il va encore se passer plein de chose
partout en france et un an pour nous
c'est la situation sociale qu'ils sont
qu'ils ont compliqué avec des revenus
qui baissent on attendait créer des
arrêtés qui viennent qui viennent
confirmer ce qu'ils sont pour l'instant
des promesses en l'air une opération de
blocage qui a interpellé les pouvoirs
publics un puisque la ministre de la
culture en personne s'est déplacé sur
place samedi soir roselyne bachelot en a
profité pour discuter avec les artistes
et tenter d'apaiser leurs inquiétudes
après une année plus que compliquée
qu'il n'est pas prêt de se terminer
elle a tenu à rappeler que le
gouvernement était mobilisé pour
anticiper une sortie de crise
je me suis rendu ce soir au théâtre de
l'odéon occupé depuis trois jours je
comprends les inquiétudes notamment sur
les suites de l'année blanche
ils le savent mon objectif est de
poursuivre la protection de l'emploi
artistique autant que nécessaire nous
poursuivrons nos échanges
une visite surprise de roselyne bachelot
qui a plus ou moins rassuré les
intermittents du spectacle est ce qu'ils
attendent c'est que la ministre de la
culture transforme ses paroles en actes
roselyne bachelot vous a transmis hier
soir le même message qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle s'adresse à nous qu'elle nous
écoute nous écoute
visiblement avec attention mais une fois
de plus on a eu aucune réponse aux
questions qu'on pose ni la promesse que
l'année blanche serait renouvelé pour
les intermittents du spectacle ni
l'engagement qu'il y ait un plan pour
l'emploi artistique emploi pour l'emploi
des intermittents du spectacle le
gouvernement qui a fermé fin octobre
lors du deuxième confinement les
théâtres musées cinémas et lieux
culturels pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus n'a pas donné de
date de réouverture les pouvoirs publics
attendent les résultats de plusieurs
concerts tester une amélioration de la
situation sanitaire avant de se
prononcer